elisa loncón lleva toda su vida
defendiendo y enseñando el marco de un
gol la lengua del pueblo originario
mayoritario en chile los mapuches que
representan el 10 por ciento de la
población chilena
de crédito representa a ser una política
genocida
mi vida
tengo originaria aquí presente un
recurso ante el ministerio de educación
atrás que se publicará un decreto que
convierte el mapudungún en una
asignatura optativa y no obligatoria
como hasta ahora para los niños mapuches
la la lengua indígena son parte de los
derechos humanos fundamentales defensora
de su lengua y líder social elisa es una
de los 39 candidatos mapuches que opta a
uno de los 17 escaños reservados a
pueblos originarios de los 155
disponibles para escribir una nueva
constitución en chile
nuestro interés es llegar a la
constitución es en pos de esa justicia
histórica pero al mismo tiempo de
nuestras contribuciones como naciones
originarias buscan la plurinacionalidad
y la nueva constitución chilena
aportando su visión de la naturaleza
para dejar atrás un modelo neoliberal
donde el agua y los territorios han sido
muchas veces privatizados aunque 17
escaños no les parecen suficientes por
primera vez en la historia podrán votar
por sus propios representantes
yo estoy esperanzada este es un sueño es
un sueño del pueblo mapuche que yo
escuché desde pequeña y que bueno en el
tiempo que llevo de vida también lo he
acariciado y lo he vuelto a soñar y yo
creo que algo alcanzaremos en esta en
este primer intento de tener los escaños
reservados un sueño para un pueblo que
necesita aún justicia llegar al siglo 21
para por primera vez en muchos siglos
ser reconocidos como parte de la
institucionalidad